[Music]
all right destroy Trump media and of
course Liberal Democrats they'll do
anything to distract from the
president's successes and they are
numerous but look at this a new Gallup
poll survey satisfaction with the US
direction now at a 12-year high numbers
don't lie facts don't lie here with
reaction the author of the new book it
chronicles all the president's success
and a little over 500 days it's called
Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback amazon.com
bookstores everywhere former Speaker of
the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich let's go to what it was
unfolding today and what we now know
about there were about fifteen lead
investigators in this case and at least
five of them the lead guys hated Trump
and liked Hillary Clinton I mean how
could any investigation like that and
the same people got involved in the
quote Trump Russian probe immediately
thereafter how could there be any
legitimacy to Muller's case if that's
the origins of this well I look I don't
think there is any legitimacy and I
think it goes back to something that we
need to have a much deeper national
debate above there really is a deep
state that deep state it that the
Justice Department gave 97% of its
donations in 2016 to Hillary Clinton the
language they use I mean if you imagine
a government employee who used the same
language about African Americans or
Latinos or Jewish Americans or Muslim
Americans that they use in some of those
quotes about Trump supporters you would
have screams to high heaven it's clear
that you had an attitude at the very
senior levels not down at the local
caseworker not down at the level of the
local offices but in the Washington
headquarters both in the Justice
Department and in the FBI the senior
figures by any plausible standard are
corrupt and they clearly were operating
on the premise that Hillary was going to
get to be President
and therefore anything they said or did
was fine because she'd cover it up but
if they did their job they would have
sent the entire 2016 election into into
utter chaos but their animus their
antipathy their hate it's downright
hatred why are you laughing for
President Trump and you're right you and
its supporters the people that voted for
him why are you laughing
look if people if they look if people
have done their job Hillary would have
faced jail time in 1978 and 79 when she
made 98 thousand dollars on a one
thousand dollar investment in cattle
futures which the Wall Street Journal
figured out was like a six trillion to
one impossibility should we now conclude
there's no equal justice under the law
equal application of our laws know that
Clinton has one standard and the rest of
us are screwed no we should conclude
that the American Left is quite
comfortable with corruption because it's
so deeply despises the American system
whether that is Barack Obama whether it
is the Attorney General under Obama
whether it is co me or Mueller all of
these people are the same people and
they go back for over a decade you can
go back and find them again and again
coming up in ways I was just with fun
economist was talking about this is an
American election
we're not the former Soviet Union we're
not Venezuela or least I didn't think so
but if this stands and it appears it
does I don't show me where Hillary's
going to get the indictment she deserved
and when is this witch-hunt going to
stop when it was all predicated on on
the the biggest anti Trump witch hunters
in the world proven by their statements
well okay first of all I don't know that
anybody who's on the corruption side of
this is necessarily safe but it unravels
gradually and it keeps unraveling it's
going to keep unraveling some more every
week that goes by
we learn new things they're horrifying
things and frankly they should remind
all of us how close we came to losing
the country that you have between Obama
and Clinton a total disregard for the
American tradition a total disregard for
the truth whether they were lying about
Benghazi or they were lying about bin
Laden or they're lying about the
Russians or they're lying about the
campaign these people didn't care
because they came out of a left-wing
background that assumed here's all these
values are nonsense I will concede the
point and patience is not my greatest
virtue not that I have a lot of you know
great virtues that you deserve that
people need but in all seriousness and I
know this is the beginning are you
confident that what should be the equal
application of laws especially with
Hillary and especially a get Muller's
team is as corrupt as commis team was
going after investigating Clinton it's
the same people they press it's all
started with the same people which would
render it illegitimate I believe that
people who want to preserve the rule of
law have to keep the pressure up you and
I very much admired what senator hatch
was doing today but senator grass he was
doing I look forward to congressman good
luck tomorrow
people are getting aroused and they're
moving yeah
all right mr. speaker Congrats on the
success of the book out in bookstores
amazon.com